Générique
...
-Bonjour à tous et bienvenue
dans "Politiques, à table !"
sur LCP,
l'émission où on parle cuisine,
alimentation,
agriculture, écologie et politique.
François-Xavier Demaison,
bonjour
et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation
et avec moi pour présenter,
Jean-Pierre Montanay.
-Bonjour, Brigitte.
-Vous êtes humoriste et acteur.
Vous avez été révélé
au grand public en 2008,
au cinéma avec le biopic
"Coluche, l'histoire d'un mec",
qui vous vaut
une nomination aux César en 2009
catégorie meilleur acteur.
Depuis, on vous a vu dans :
"Le petit Nicolas",
où vous interprétez Bouillon,
le pion.
Vous avez été remarqué aussi
dans la comédie dramatique
"Comme des frères",
d'Hugo Gélin.
Vous commencez votre carrière
tardivement, un peu avant 30 ans.
Vous revenez à vos premières amours,
le théâtre,
après un détour perdu par la finance
à New York. Assez du fric,
à vous la vie d'artiste
et de vigneron.
Vous possédez le domaine
Mirmanda, qui se trouve
en Catalogne française,
un indice
pour le menu du jour.
-Menu aux saveurs du sud,
avec une fideua catalane
et en dessert, un fiadone corse.
-Dans Le dessous des plats,
des vignes chez les Ch'tis ?
Avec le réchauffement climatique,
les Hauts-de-France cultivent
du raisin.
Dégustation dans l'émission.
-Dans Les pieds dans le plat,
attention aux préjugés.
La cuisine américaine
n'est pas que de la malbouffe.
Elle peut régaler.
Reportage à suivre.
-Allez, on passe à table.
Tout de suite,
Cuisine et confidences.
-François-Xavier,
pour parler de votre assiette,
histoire de rendre hommage
à Coluche, incarné à l'écran,
j'avais envie de raconter
l'histoire d'un mec
à table et non pas sur le pont
de l'Alma. Un mec normal,
blanc, au resto, et qui regarde
dans son assiette.
Pas con, le mec.
Au bout d'une demi-heure,
y a un autre mec qui arrive
et il voit un mec
qui regarde dans l'assiette.
"Dis donc,
"qu'est-ce que vous faites ?"
"Je suis emmerdé,
"j'ai laissé tomber mes lunettes
dans ma paëlla."
L'autre lui dit : "Pas une paëlla,
c'est une fideua."
L'autre lui dit : "Vous savez,
sans mes lunettes..."
Rigolote ?
-Elle est très bien.
Rires
-Dans la version originale,
vous le savez,
le mec est sur le pont de l'Alma,
et il confond la Loire et la Seine,
mais au-delà
de l'imitation de Coluche,
pour atterrir
sur la fideua, j'ai une question :
qu'est-ce qui vous fait
la préférer à la paëlla,
qui lui ressemble
fichtrement ?
Une pointe de snobisme
ou votre amour aveugle
pour la Catalogne ?
-Exactement,
c'est mon amour aveugle
pour la Catalogne. Aveugle.
L'amour rend aveugle,
puisque c'est une femme
qui m'a conduit en Catalogne.
-Ah !
-Je suis tombé amoureux
d'une Catalane très attachée
à sa terre,
et donc, c'était pas négociable.
Il a fallu que...
qu'on emménage en Catalogne
une partie...
On a acheté une maison,
avec des animaux et voilà.
Elle est très proche de sa terre,
de sa grand-mère,
de toute sa famille,
de sa mère, qui habite
à 50 s de la maison,
donc on est vraiment en clan.
C'est un village
qui s'appelle Thuir, que j'adore,
et c'est une spécialité.
Ils sont très marqués
par l'Espagne, ils sont
à quelques minutes
de l'Espagne.
La famille de ma femme
a fait la Retirada.
Ces familles d'Espagnols...
-Je connais la remontada.
La Retirada...
-Ce sont les républicains
qui ont fui le franquisme
et qui sont venus,
qui ont passé la frontière
pour fuir le franquisme.
Et voilà, et qui ont...
travaillé dur,
et qui, voilà, ont ramené,
quand même, dans leurs bagages,
des recettes espagnoles.
On est marqués
par la proximité de l'Espagne,
et par cette culture espagnole.
La fideua,
ça se mange beaucoup
en Catalogne.
-Oui, mais la paëlla,
c'est quand même
avec du riz. Là, on se retrouve...
C'est des pâtes ?
-Exactement.
Ce sont des pâtes
et je trouve ça
absolument délicieux.
-On va goûter.
-On goûte.
Allez, allons-y.
-Brigitte,
c'est votre 1re fideua ?
-C'est ma première.
Ca se fête !
-On a envie de savoir...
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
-Elle est très bonne.
-Elle est merveilleuse.
-Après, je pourrai
vous en parler un peu.
-Est-ce qu'elle est comme là-bas ?
-Elle est parfaite.
-Elle a la même saveur ?
-Alors, les Catalans
rajoutent de l'aïoli.
-Oui !
-Une espèce de...
-Avec un peu d'ail.
-Un peu beaucoup.
-Pour relever un peu le plat.
-C'est une sauce blanche
qu'ils mettent sur le plat.
Ils en mangent beaucoup.
-Vous en mangez le lundi,
vous sentez l'aïoli
jusqu'au jeudi soir.
-Meilleure que celle
de votre femme ?
-On va avoir des ennuis,
Jean-Pierre.
On va avoir des ennuis !
-Joker.
-Est-ce que c'est une insulte
si on dit que c'est une paëlla
avec des pâtes ?
-Non, c'est ça.
C'est pas une insulte.
-C'est du vermicelle,
ou c'est des pâtes ?
-Je vais vous raconter.
Trois choses à savoir :
on parle de fideua à la catalane,
mais la légende
dit que ce sont
des pêcheurs de Gandia,
un port de pêche
entre Valence et Alicante,
qui auraient inventé
cette recette en 1915.
En haute mer,
ils ont voulu faire une paëlla,
et plus de riz !
Alors, le cuisinier
a remplacé le riz
par ces fideus.
J'ai les vermicelles.
Il a remplacé ça
par ces petits vermicelles.
De retour sur terre,
la recette fut un succès.
Les restaurateurs l'ont adoptée
et au fil du temps,
c'est devenu un plat
complètement ibérique,
cousin de la paëlla. La fideua
va s'exporter à l'étranger.
A Paris, on peut la trouver
au restaurant
Le Derrick Catalan.
L'authentique fideua
est catalane,
vous nous expliquerez,
et composée de fruits de mer :
gambas, moules, seiches.
On peut servir
une fideua
avec de l'encre de seiche.
J'adore celle-ci.
-Moi aussi.
J'adore l'encre
de seiche, de toute façon.
C'est une belle histoire.
Comme quoi,
les plus grands plats,
finalement,
c'est le fruit de circonstances.
On dit souvent au théâtre
que l'art vit de contraintes
et meurt de libertés.
La cuisine aussi.
C'est vrai,
la tarte Tatin,
c'est une tarte ratée.
-Renversée !
-Le poulet Marengo,
il doit faire avec,
sur le champ de bataille,
le cuisinier de Napoléon.
C'est rigolo de voir
que ces grands plats naissent
de circonstances
et de contraintes.
-La fideua,
on la trouve partout ?
-Oui, oui, je crois.
Je crois. En tout cas,
dans tout bon restaurant catalan,
vous avez de la fideua.
Vous avez la cargolade aussi.
Ce sont les escargots à...
l'aïoli.
Tout est à base d'aïoli...
-Avec de l'ail !
-Comme Beatles-Rolling Stones,
vous, hormis votre épouse,
qu'est-ce que vous préférez ?
Une bonne paëlla
ou une bonne fideua ?
-Je crois qu'avec le temps,
je préfère la fideua.
-D'accord.
C'est vrai,
quand elle est croustillante...
Ce sont des plats secs.
Il y a un peu de bouillon...
-Là, c'est pas sec.
-Au four, ils sèchent,
contrairement à un risotto
ou un riz avec de la sauce.
C'est gratiné.
-Y a du cremat dans le fond,
ce qu'on appelle...
Moi, ce que j'aime aussi,
c'est les riz, les arroz.
-Les Espagnols
savent très bien le faire.
Votre femme,
elle a ce petit poêlon ?
C'est indispensable.
-Oui.
-Elle a pas que ça,
visiblement !
Rires
Il y a une recette familiale ?
Qui prépare la fideua ?
-C'est surtout sa mère.
-Voilà, c'est ça.
-C'est surtout sa mère,
qui cuisine très bien.
Ma femme a d'autres sujets
d'intérêts.
-Donc, elle a pas récupéré
la recette.
C'est plutôt
quand vous allez
chez belle-maman ?
-Elle n'a récupéré
ni la recette ni l'envie.
-D'accord.
-Elle n'aime pas trop cuisiner.
C'est plutôt moi qui cuisine.
-Vous savez
la préparer ?
-J'en ai fait une, une fois,
mais pas...
Ca a été assez rare,
mais je cuisine,
dans le respect du produit,
bien entendu.
-Qu'est-ce qui est
difficile, pour vous, à réussir ?
-Chaque étape.
-C'est long.
-C'est de la patience.
-C'est le bouillon.
-Savoir
à quel moment on met le bouillon,
on rajoute les pâtes.
Voilà, tout doit être fait
dans un timing qui est assez...
-Contraignant.
-C'est fascinant.
A un mariage, le lendemain,
le mariage d'une amie de ma femme,
il y avait un énorme...
Un énorme poêlon,
et puis, il y avait le cuisinier,
qui était là avec son bâton,
comme ça, pour...
C'est une vraie tradition,
un vrai rituel.
-Je suis surpris quand,
en Espagne,
ils font des énormes paëllas.
On se dit que ça va pas être bon.
La paëlla fait presque
10 m de diamètre,
et ils arrivent
à faire des bonnes paëllas.
Ils sont bons.
-"Je travaille
dans le respect du produit."
Qu'est-ce que vous faites,
en cuisine ?
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous préparer ?
-Je suis pas un grand cuisinier,
et souvent, j'ai pas le temps,
c'est pour ça
que dans le livre,
j'ai recueilli quelques recettes
un peu faciles.
-Alors, voilà, c'est le livre
dont on va parler après.
"Tournée générale :
ma route des vins",
on va en reparler,
mais il y a des recettes de cuisine.
-Des choses assez simples,
finalement,
mais c'est vrai,
moi, je pars du produit,
vraiment, voilà...
Je le fais souvent griller.
Avec l'accent du sud
Là-bas, ils font griller.
-L'huile d'olive ?
-L'huile d'olive.
-Une viande, un poisson ?
-Une viande, un poisson.
C'est des choses que j'adore.
J'aime bien grignoter, la tapas.
Quand il y a plein de choses
sur la table, j'adore ça.
-Vous êtes gourmand ?
-Oui, j'aime bien déguster,
comme pour les vins.
J'aime boire un verre
et goûter un autre vin.
-La curiosité.
-Exactement.
-La culture, on en a parlé,
des tapas,
c'est pas français.
En Catalogne,
côté français, ça existe ?
Par capillarité ?
-Oui, exactement.
-C'est un art de vivre,
les tapas.
-Moi, j'aime bien ça.
-On passe de bar en bar,
on boit un coup.
-J'ai du mal à m'enfermer
dans un plat. Vous voyez ?
-Et la finger food,
ça vous plaît ?
-Oui, j'adore ça.
Pour moi, la finger food,
c'est l'héritière de la tapas,
de la formule tapas, c'est...
Y a plein de choses,
on grignote,
on boit un verre. Comme vous dites,
aller de bar en bar.
Avec ma femme, on appelle ça
le "barathon".
On fait un verre, un bar.
Un verre, un bar. Comme ça,
ça nous permet de sa balader...
-De déambuler.
Et au bout de trois,
on pense avoir fait
la tournée des grands ducs,
une soirée extraordinaire.
-42 km de bars,
ça fait quelques verres.
-Ca s'appelle un marathon.
-Et alors, donc, vous avez...
Il y a la finger food,
et aussi le grignotage sans arrêt.
Vous êtes du genre
à manger un peu toute la journée ?
-Non, j'essaie de me contenir,
eu égard à cet emploi
de jeune premier
que j'ai encore au cinéma,
de jeune romantique.
J'essaie de maintenir... Non, non,
je suis très gourmand, et donc,
il faut se donner quelques règles.
Je mange peu le manger,
je ne grignote pas dans la journée.
A l'apéro,
je peux pas m'empêcher de...
-C'est le moment préféré ?
-On se détend,
on boit un verre de blanc.
Sympa.
-On a compris que votre femme
vous a converti au catalanisme.
Et la cuisine française ?
"Demaison", c'est français !
Ca fait penser
à la blanquette,
au boeuf bourguignon.
-Mon plat préféré.
-Vous aimez ces totems ?
-Mon préféré : la blanquette.
Le boeuf bourguignon,
j'adore ça.
-Pour le vin ?
-Oui, du bourgogne !
J'adore
quand il est bien fondant,
voilà, j'adore...
Oui,
le fromage.
-Quand même.
-Bon vivant ?
-J'ai beaucoup d'amis chefs,
restaurateurs.
-On les retrouve.
-Gilles Goujon,
Anne-Sophie Pic.
Il y a aussi...
-Pierre Hermé.
-Mon ami pâtissier.
Non, c'est une vraie...
Une vraie passion. La table,
c'est une vraie passion.
-Vous faites votre marché,
un peu ?
Vous allez choisir vos produits,
en fonction des saisons ?
Du bio, tout ça ? Ou non ?
Je sens un peu de...
-Oui, on essaie de se faire...
Dans le sud, on se fait livrer
par les agriculteurs du coin.
On a une cagette en début de semaine
avec des produits
de saison, des légumes de saison
et c'est vrai que là aussi,
c'est merveilleux, de mettre
des aubergines au four
avec un peu de sauce miso.
C'est délicieux.
C'est tout simple.
Il suffit d'avoir un bon produit
pour avoir un bon plat.
-Un pays est connu
pour ses bons produits :
l'île de Beauté.
Vous avez des racines corses.
On en parlera au dessert.
Quand vous faites
de la cuisine salée,
vous pensez à vos racines ?
-Bien entendu.
-Vous sortez...
Qu'est-ce que vous nous faites,
côté corse ?
-Vous avez les beignets de brocciu.
Extraordinaires.
-Grand classique.
-Vous avez
les beignets de brocciu,
vous avez les...
Le fiadone, le dessert.
-On en parlera.
-Vous avez tout ce qui est...
polenta, tout ce qui est
plats traditionnels corses.
-Il y a beaucoup
de charcuteries aussi.
A tomber.
-Les fromages, à tomber.
Les vins sont merveilleux.
-Comment on appelle
le jambon corse ?
-Le prizuttu.
-Le prizuttu, réservé aux Corses.
Les touristes,
ils n'y ont jamais droit.
On n'en produit pas assez
pour fournir la demande.
-Les cuisines
du monde, ça vous intéresse ?
-Enormément.
-Il y a des cuisines
que vous n'aimez pas ?
-J'ai une vraie appétence...
J'adore la cuisine asiatique.
Je suis gourmand et curieux,
donc j'adore la cuisine asiatique.
Mon père a vécu au Vietnam
pendant des années.
Il y a une vraie culture
de la cuisine asiatique à la maison.
On a beaucoup
d'amis asiatiques.
-Petit, il y avait à la maison...
-On allait...
Mon grand-père ne mangeait
que de la cuisine asiatique.
-Beaucoup de riz, aussi ?
A base de riz ?
-Les cuisines
vietnamienne,
cambodgienne.
On était des amateurs
de phôs, de bobuns.
-Avant que ce soit la mode,
avant l'heure.
-Oui, oui, non...
Exactement. On a toujours baigné
dans cette cuisine.
Je me souviens
de moments avec mon grand-père
où on allait
dans des petits restaurants
dans le 13e,
des restos chinois dans le 13e,
sur la dalle.
-C'est les meilleurs,
sur la dalle, dans le 13e.
-La cuisine japonaise ?
Les sushis,
très à la mode ?
-Très à la mode.
On a
de très bons sushis à Paris.
La cuisine japonaise,
et les bentos aussi.
Y a pas que les sushis
dans la cuisine japonaise.
Il y a d'autres choses.
C'est une cuisine
d'une finesse incroyable.
Je suis assez grand public.
Je suis assez...
ouvert d'esprit.
-Universel.
-Exactement !
-Quand vous partez en vacances,
la cuisine est un moteur
qui permet d'orienter
votre destination ?
Vous préférez aller au Vietnam
qu'en Islande ?
Si on parle de la bouffe.
-Exactement.
Je suis une vraie éponge,
donc quand j'arrive,
par exemple, à Venise
avec ma femme pendant 4 jours,
je vais parler
avec un accent italien.
Ma chérie
n'en peut plus !
On va se faire des risottos.
Je me souviens d'un risotto
au Metropole,
un risotto vitello...
...avec un...
un vin de Quintarelli,
Valpolicella Classico,
de Giuseppe Quintarelli.
Moment suspendu.
C'était si bon
que le lendemain,
on est retournés au même endroit
pour manger et boire la même chose.
-Ah oui.
-C'est rare, ça,
de retourner le lendemain.
-"On ne trouvera pas mieux
"que ce miracle."
-Attention,
vous êtes en train de dire que
la cuisine italienne est meilleure
que l'espagnole.
-Sérieusement ?
-Oui, écoutez, je ne sais pas.
C'est différent. Voilà.
Je ne cherche pas...
A Paris, aujourd'hui,
il y a 4 restos italiens
par rue.
-Oui.
Les restaurants espagnols,
il y en a peu.
-Oui, assez peu.
-C'est une vraie culture,
une vraie gastronomie.
-C'est vrai.
-Vous êtes plutôt bistro,
étoilé, cuisine du monde ?
Qu'est-ce qui vous motive ?
-Tout !
Tout, je suis tout.
-Tout ?
-Je suis tout.
J'adore les petits bistros.
J'adore les...
Et puis, oui,
j'ai une appétence aussi,
de temps en temps,
à aller chez un grand chef,
un grand créateur,
un artiste. Pour moi,
ce sont des artistes, ces gens-là.
-Les gueuletons,
les copains, les amis...
Vous êtes plus à l'aise
dans les bistros où ça chante ?
-Partout.
Je suis à l'aise partout !
-Non, mais parfois, c'est vrai
qu'il y a un protocole,
du code dans les étoilés.
-Il y a, d'ailleurs,
dans mon spectacle, un moment
où vous avez un serveur qui arrive
et va parler d'un plat.
Souvent, ils vous parlent
comme si vous étiez
en phase terminale.
"Nous sommes sur une escabèche
d'écrevisse, puis nous irons
"sur un pigeonneau farci
à la chair de crabe d'Alaska,
"jus de griottes, accompagné
de sa galette de sarrasin,
"cuite à la vapeur d'un geyser
du désert du Serengeti."
-Votre dernier mot ?
-On ne sait pas quoi
trouver dans l'assiette.
-C'est un rituel, assez théâtral,
parce que moi,
mes premières émotions,
quand mes parents, pour fêter
un bac ou un diplôme,
m'emmenaient,
c'était un peu le rituel,
dans un restaurant,
qui était
beaucoup plus accessible
qu'aujourd'hui,
il ne faut pas se mentir,
ils m'emmenaient
et il y avait ce rituel
des serveurs, de l'ambiance.
Ca m'a fasciné,
ce côté très théâtral
des grandes maisons.
-C'est une expérience.
Vous vous en souvenez.
Vous racontez
ce qu'on a dit,
donc ça vous a marqué.
C'est réussi.
-Exactement, je crois
que c'est ça aussi
qui est formidable,
c'est que le service,
j'admire les métiers de la salle,
le service a aussi son importance,
c'est le...
Comment on va vous parler
d'un vin,
vous parler d'un plat.
C'est la façon dont on va vous
en parler qui va vous donner envie,
comme quand on visite
un musée d'art contemporain,
et qu'à côté de nous, on a
un passionné qui va dire :
"C'est le moment
"de sa vie où voilà,
"Jackson Pollock n'a plus d'argent.
Il peint sur son lit."
Par exemple.
-C'est vrai, ça ?
-Oui.
-Je savais pas.
-Quand vous allez
au MoMA, à New York,
vous avez un lit de Jackson Pollock,
qu'il a peint
avec sa méthode particulière.
-Ah oui ?
-Son génie, quoi.
-Son lancer.
Au cinéma, par exemple,
il vous arrive souvent d'avoir
des scènes où vous mangez ?
Vous mangez vraiment ?
-Au cinéma, c'est très...
C'est chiant, les scènes au cinéma,
parce qu'il faut pas faire faux,
pas comme
dans les séries américaines,
où les nanas ont une pomme.
Elles la prennent,
c'est le déjeuner.
C'est pas réaliste. Il faut y aller.
C'est pas "La grande bouffe".
On tourne pas
"La grande bouffe",
mais bon. Au début,
vous êtes très content.
-Oui.
Quand il faut refaire la prise
15 fois...
-C'est plus compliqué.
-On remet des choses
dans l'assiette ?
-Il faut être raccord.
Si je fais ça,
vous voyez, comme ça,
je vous parle.
-Si ça marche pas,
c'est pas raccord,
il faut remettre de la fideua.
-Ben oui.
Il faut la même quantité,
sinon ça fait faux.
Si je fais ça, on n'y croit plus.
-A la fin, on n'a plus
envie de manger,
ni de faire la prise !
-15 prises, oui...
-On s'affame,
généralement.
On ne mange pas,
quand c'est l'après-midi.
On a de la réserve.
Si vous sortez
de table et qu'on vous sert
un gratin... Je peux contourner
le truc. De temps en temps,
je fais comme si je...
J'essaie de dire mes phrases
sans avoir mangé.
-Pas facile de manger
et de parler en même temps.
-Exactement !
-On va voir si vous êtes vraiment
incollable : c'est le quiz.
-Vous avez joué
dans le film "Le petit Nicolas"
le rôle de Bouillon,
Brigitte l'a précisé.
De son vrai nom, M. Dubon,
surveillant
de l'école de Nicolas.
Surnommé ainsi, car il dit souvent :
"Regardez-moi
"dans les yeux."
Dans le bouillon, il y a
des yeux.
Sauriez-vous nous dire qui a eu
cette autre citation
à propos du bouillon ?
Jean-Pierre Montanay
lit la question.
Il lit les propositions.
Paul Bocuse, l'un des papes
de la gastronomie française.
...
De Funès,
qui a tourné dans des films
où il était question
de restaurants.
-"Le grand restaurant".
-"L'aile ou la cuisse" !
-Je crois que c'est
Auguste Escoffier.
-Alexandre Dumas,
dans son "Grand dico de cuisine".
Voilà.
-Bravo.
-2e quiz.
-Vous me nourrissez aussi
de culture
et je vous remercie.
-Par votre mère,
vous avez du sang corse,
île du fameux brocciu,
ce fromage de chèvre ou de brebis.
Ces affirmations
sur le brocciu
sont-elles vraies ?
-"Brocciu".
-Comment vous dites ?
-Brocciu.
-Du brocciu.
Brigitte Boucher
lit la question.
Brigitte Boucher lit
la première affirmation.
...
-Attention, piège !
Brigitte Boucher relit
l'affirmation.
Si vous donnez la réponse,
Jean-Pierre, c'est pas possible !
-J'ai dit qu'il y avait un piège.
-Eh bien non.
-C'est faux. C'est vrai.
-Il y a une AOC ?
-Faux, il s'agit
du même fromage,
donc c'est la même chose.
-Le piège. Le brocciu
et le brocciu corse,
c'est la même chose.
-Voilà.
-Oui ! Ah, j'avais pas compris
la question
Je croyais que le brocciu était
protégé par une AOC.
-NON.
-Le brocciu corse est protégé
par une AOC : faux.
-J'ai pas compris.
-Il n'y a pas d'AOC.
-J'aurais répondu bon.
-Si, il y a une AOC.
C'est le même fromage.
Il n'y a pas de différence
entre le corse,
qui a une AOC, et le normal.
-Donc, il y a une AOC.
-J'avais faux.
Soyons honnêtes.
-Allez,
le cousin italien du brocciu
est la fontina.
-Faux !
-Faux ! C'est la ricotta.
Bien joué. Dans la cuisine
corse, on farcit même
les sardines au brocciu ?
-Faux !
-Vrai !
-Oui.
-Vrai.
-Sardines au brocciu.
-J'ai décidé de répondre
faux.
-"Faux" à tout.
Le mois idéal pour se régaler
d'un brocciu frais est août ?
-Faux !
Octobre à juin.
-Oui.
C'est comme le figatellu.
C'est saisonnier aussi.
Manger un figatellu...
en plein mois de juillet,
c'est pas...
That's not relevant.
-Ca se fait pas. Alors,
vous savez, c'est souvent
à l'occasion d'un déjeuner
que se nouent les deals politiques,
que se fait l'histoire.
C'est la Brève de comptoir.
François-Xavier Demaison,
on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à une anecdote.
Mangez tranquille.
Une anecdote
autour d'un repas,
en politique, éventuellement,
si vous aviez.
Vous avez une anecdote ?
-C'est une anecdote
de tournage, mais qui est...
On avait préparé la...
Pendant le déjeuner,
on était avec Benoît Magimel,
André Wilms pour une scène
de cascade, et donc,
on déjeunait.
Le cascadeur vient et nous dit :
"Ne vous inquiétez pas,
"la sécurité,
c'est ma priorité."
Très bien, tant mieux.
-Heureusement !
-Donc, je devais, dans la scène,
assommer, tuer André Wilms,
en lui éclatant
une carafe de sucre sur le crâne.
La sécurité,
c'est ma priorité.
On termine notre plat.
On se fait...
légèrement raccorder.
On arrive sur le plateau,
et donc,
je m'engueule avec André,
je saisis
la carafe de sucre
et je lui éclate
sur la tête.
Il s'effondre.
On entend : "Oh !"
Quel acteur ! Enfin...
Rires
C'est incroyable.
André ? André, ça va ?
En fait,
la carafe n'avait pas explosé.
Elle s'était figée.
Et il avait, le pauvre,
été ouvert de là jusque-là,
avec une espèce de crête de...
...de sucre, de...
Enfin, de...
-La priorité...
-Je revois le cascadeur,
qui regarde la carafe et qui fait :
"Je comprends pas."
Une petite anecdote de tournage.
-Sinon,
il est parti à l'hôpital ?
-Oui, il a été transporté.
-La scène était bonne ?
-Dans le film.
C'est celle qui a été montée.
On en a tourné une.
-Il a pas voulu refaire
l'expérience ?
-Il pouvait pas.
-Elle est rigolote,
comme dirait Coluche.
-Très bien.
Dans cette émission, on mange,
mais on boit aussi.
On a décidé...
Vous nous avez demandé un vin du...
Roussillon.
-Pour accompagner
cette fideua. C'est cohérent.
-Vous y avez un domaine.
J'imagine que vous connaissez bien
cette région.
On ne va pas faire
une dégustation à l'aveugle.
C'est un vin rouge.
-Tout à fait.
-Du Roussillon.
Je vous donne
une information.
Si on fait une dégustation
à l'aveugle, est-ce que vous sauriez
dire un peu... ?
-Excellent, moi.
-Oui, moi aussi.
Il sirote.
Mh !
Magnifique.
C'est très, très beau.
Je pense que ce sont
des cépages autochtones.
-C'est Roussillon.
Roussillon.
-Oui, donc syrah,
grenache, mourvèdre. C'est ça...
-Oui.
-...les cépages, avec un léger
vieillissement en barrique.
Voilà.
-Voilà, la spécialiste
du vin, c'est Brigitte.
Alors ?
-Alors, vous avez pas
d'idée particulière ?
-Il me fait penser
à ce qu'on fait
dans notre région,
au domaine
Mirmanda.
-C'est vrai ?
-Oui.
-C'est Cibelle.
-Ah ben voilà.
-C'est Cibelle de Mirmanda.
C'est votre domaine.
Vous pouvez nous en parler un peu ?
-D'abord,
on le félicite.
Il a reconnu son vin.
Il aurait pu se planter.
-Effectivement.
-Vous avez bon goût à l'émission.
-Ca aurait été difficile.
Là, c'est un millésime 2020.
-Oui.
-Voilà, en vente actuellement.
Grenache, syrah, effectivement.
Fruité, des goûts de cerise,
de cassis, légèrement
vanillé, c'est en appellation
"vin de France".
Et donc, la région, on est...
en Languedoc-Roussillon.
-Dans notre gamme, on a le...
...ce qu'on appelle
la grande cuvée,
qui est en Côtes du Roussillon,
et là, Cibelle,
on est en vin de France,
parce que ça nous permet
des assemblages
un peu rigolos.
-Il y a un assemblage
très étrange.
-On a mis un peu de vin blanc.
On a le droit ! En vin de France,
vous avez le droit
de mettre un peu de...
-Au dernier moment ?
Ca, je savais pas.
-C'est pas un kir.
Pas au moment de servir.
-Bien sûr !
-C'est ce que je lisais.
-Au moment
de mettre en barrique.
-Il y a des carignans
noirs vinifiés avec des grenaches
blancs, viognier,
et chardonnay ?
-Exactement.
Tout ça fait que c'est...
Résultat :
vous avez ce côté un peu...
Oui, ce petit acidulé
en fin de bouche.
-Un peu fruité,
un peu de légèreté.
-On peut se le permettre.
-C'est toléré ?
-Beaucoup de grands vignerons
du sud de la France
sont sortis de l'appellation
pour laisser court
à leur inspiration,
et à leur génie. Par exemple,
si je pense à Eloi Durrbach,
qui avait le domaine Trevallon
dans les Bouches-du-Rhône, voilà,
il est sorti de l'appellation.
Ca a permis de mettre du cabernet
dans sa syrah et d'arriver
à ces assemblages extraordinaires.
-On crée toujours ?
On a cet esprit-là ?
Sinon, quand on reste
dans des appellations classiques,
on se retrouve avec toujours
les mêmes cépages.
-Exactement. Après, ça a du bon.
Quand vous êtes en Bourgogne,
il y a des appellations...
Ce sont deux écoles :
c'est faire des vins
dans l'appellation,
le cahier des charges,
fidèle à un terroir,
fidèle à l'appellation.
Et puis, des cuvées
où on s'amuse un peu
et aller... Voilà.
-C'est Dominique Laporte ?
-C'est mon associé,
Dominique Laporte,
Meilleur Sommelier de France.
On a créé ce domaine il y a 5 ans.
-On va continuer
à parler du vin, bien sûr.
Derrière une bonne fideua
se cache
un bon vin et c'est :
Le dessous des plats.
Alors, vous,
le professionnel du vin,
vous savez que
le dérèglement climatique a
des conséquences importantes
sur la vigne.
Ca a donné des idées :
planter du raisin dans des régions
jusqu'ici pas assez chaudes,
comme dans les Hauts-de-France.
Le premier millésime vient
de sortir de terre.
Hélène Bonduelle
et Marion Devauchelle.
-On est dans la parcelle de vigne
plantée il y a trois ans.
C'est le grand jour
de la vendange.
-On se croirait dans le sud.
Pourtant, nous sommes dans le Nord,
début octobre,
et il fait encore 25 degrés.
C'est une récolte particulière
pour ces bénévoles :
sur cette parcelle,
pour la première fois,
ils vont vendanger.
-Elles sont...
lourdes, pleines de soleil.
Le soleil des Hauts-de-France.
-Dans les grappes.
-Ah oui, dans les grappes.
C'est extraordinaire !
J'aurais jamais cru ça.
Ca fait 25 ans
que j'habite ici.
Jamais j'aurais cru
qu'on aurait eu des vignes
et qu'on puisse faire le vin.
-Il y a un peu une mutation
avec le climat.
Est-ce un bien, un mal ?
Je sais pas,
on verra la suite après.
Il y a un cycle normal de...
du réchauffement, donc...
On verra.
Il faut s'adapter.
-S'adapter à des sols qui changent
avec le réchauffement climatique,
c'est ce que Julien Dhaine a fait.
Il a abandonné une partie
de ses céréales
pour se consacrer à la vigne.
-On était limités
au niveau rendement.
Les cultures ne se plaisaient pas
dans ces terres.
C'est un petit challenge,
un gros challenge, même.
C'est découvrir une autre culture,
découvrir de A à Z.
On a tout à apprendre.
-Alors, le céréalier devenu vigneron
s'est formé auprès du collectif
des 130, des industriels
et des vignerons
qui se sont lancés dans le projet
il y a 3 ans.
-On s'est dit : "Que faire
"pour améliorer
la diversification ?" En même temps,
on avait le réchauffement climatique
qui devenait prégnant sur la région
et on a commencé à regarder
cette diversification.
Actuellement,
il y a 90 hectares qui sont plantés,
avec une bonne cinquantaine
d'agriculteurs concernés.
-Objectif : 200 hectares de vignes
d'ici cinq ans dans le Nord.
Le vin, lui, un chardonnay,
est assemblé ici,
dans cette ancienne sucrerie.
-La 1re sensation,
c'est un vin
assez explosif, dû à un côté
perlant, qui prend de l'ampleur
dans la bouche, un vin
pour les apéritifs. On est porté
sur les agrumes jaunes et rouges
tels que le pamplemousse.
-Deux cuvées sont commercialisées,
la 3e le sera l'an prochain.
-On est très contents des produits
que nous avons eus
pour un 1er millésime.
C'est une perspective d'avenir
assez gratifiante,
parce que, quand on arrive à avoir
cette qualité avec des vignes
qui ont seulement 3 ans,
on sait que, quand elles auront
entre 8 et 10 ans, on sera
à leur plein potentiel qualitatif,
et ce, pour longtemps,
donc on n'aura pas
à rougir de la qualité.
-Pour le moment, le vin du Nord
reste un marché de niche,
moins de 50 000 bouteilles
vendues, uniquement dans la région.
-Là, c'est le 1er millésime
dans la région,
mais vous pensez
que demain, le vin sera
essentiellement planté
dans le Nord ?
-En tout cas,
le réchauffement climatique a
des conséquences concrètes.
C'est le cas aussi en Normandie,
en Belgique.
-En Bretagne.
-Oui. J'ai goûté des vins
en Belgique très bons.
Oui, effectivement, tout ça évolue,
ce réchauffement climatique a
des conséquences à court terme
sympathiques, positives,
et puis à moyen terme et long terme
plus inquiétantes.
-Vous le voyez chez vous,
à Mirmanda,
ce réchauffement ?
Vous avez des degrés d'alcool
plus importants ?
-Il y a une grosse sécheresse,
mais nos vignes sont plantées,
on a cette chance-là, ce sont
des très vieilles vignes plantées
dans la vallée de l'Agly.
Vous avez une espèce de rivière
souterraine, donc en termes
d'hydrique, nos vignes, voilà.
-Ah oui.
-Mais c'est un vrai problème.
On produit
entre le mildiou et la sécheresse,
on produit de moins en moins
de vin.
-C'est ça,
votre récolte se réduit.
-Oui.
-Et les baies sont moins gorgées...
Surtout l'année dernière, mais...
Enfin, l'année d'avant.
Avec le vin qu'on met
en bouteille aujourd'hui.
Mais c'est... ça fait partie de...
L'homme doit s'adapter.
-Vous vous adaptez,
vous ombragez vos vignes ?
-Non, pas du tout.
-Rien du tout.
-Vous avez le droit de faire
du goutte à goutte ?
-On n'en fait pas.
Pas du tout.
Ce sont des vieilles dames de 80 ans
qui ont besoin de personne.
-80 ans, c'est vieux
pour des vignes ?
-Ben, ça peut aller bien au-delà,
100 ans, 120 ans.
-C'est déjà pas mal.
-Non, je...
Je suis profane, je savais pas.
C'est déjà pas mal pour un humain.
-C'est des beaux ceps de vigne,
bien tordus.
-Ca veut dire
que ce vin confidentiel
de Julien, un jour,
sera votre concurrent ?
-50 000 bouteilles.
-Ces vins du nord.
-Mais il faut les vendre.
-Ce sera votre concurrent
de demain ?
-Je sais pas,
parce que, de toute façon,
le Roussillon est une région qui est
récente sur les... Enfin, voilà,
en termes d'image, elle a...
elle est pas récente, je dirais,
au niveau histoire et viticulture,
mais elle est devenue
à la mode récemment,
comme ces vins du Rhône. Voilà.
Ce sont des régions qui ont
longtemps, comme on dit,
fait cracher la vigne et...
-Ou pâti de leur image.
-C'est beaucoup plus
travaillé, c'est ça.
-Des gens qui travaillent
de manière extraordinaire.
Si je pense à Danjou-Banessy,
à Gardiés, Goby, Roc des Anges,
ce sont des domaines
exceptionnels, qui sont
sur les plus grandes tables
parisiennes ou à l'étranger,
donc j'ai envie de dire
que c'est une région qui perce.
La sécheresse,
c'est vrai que c'est un problème.
Vaut mieux peut-être aller planter
des vignes en Alsace
ou en Normandie.
-On dit
qu'un vin, il y a pas que le raison,
il y a aussi le terroir, les sols,
on retrouve ça...
-Il y a aussi les hommes,
la façon dont ils travaillent.
-Les hommes
peuvent aller dans les
Hauts-de-France, mais les sols,
vous êtes plutôt sur du calcaire ?
-Argilocalcaire ou schiste.
-Sur du granit,
on aura les mêmes terroirs
pour avoir des bonnes vignes ?
-Oui, je pense.
Je pense qu'il faut attendre un peu
de voir ce que ça va donner
sur le temps.
On dit souvent,
la nature fait du vinaigre
et l'homme fait du vin.
C'est la personnalité
d'un vigneron, sa passion,
son exigence qui va faire qu'on va
avoir aussi un résultat.
Il suffit de regarder le Beaujolais,
voilà. Vous avez
Marcel Lapierre,
qui est un véritable pionnier,
qui a tranché un petit peu
avec toute cette culture
du Beaujolais nouveau.
En Beaujolais,
vous avez des artistes,
des vins exceptionnels,
des Gamay avec une floraison,
comme ça, un floral,
c'est un bouquet de fleurs.
Ces vins rouges de Beaujolais
aujourd'hui.
Les Fleurie d'Yvon Metras,
les Côte de Py de chez Foillard,
c'est des vins magnifiques.
-Mais Brigitte, les hommes,
on est vigneron de père
en fils, de grand-père,
il y a des traditions, mais là,
c'est un céréalier qui se met
au vin,
il y a pas de tradition.
-Bah oui, mais je pense
qu'il le fait pas tout seul.
Il doit être bien aidé.
-Les Belges
n'ont pas de tradition de vin.
-Non, c'est vrai. Dans le Bordelais,
des gens font du vin depuis 400 ans,
c'est difficile
d'arriver ensuite, mais
sur une production
plus confidentielle,
ils peuvent arriver
à des résultats sympas
et voilà.
-On va le goûter.
-Ils nous ont donné une bouteille
pour justement vous faire goûter.
-Rien que le nez me plaît beaucoup.
-Vous êtes fan de Chardonnay.
-Bah, c'est
un cépage extraordinaire.
-A consommer
avec modération bien sûr.
-Brigitte ?
-Il est très bon, je l'ai
goûté avant.
-On a affaire à un connaisseur,
je sais pas faire ces bruitages.
Je le trouve
bon, mais je suis...
-Très bon. C'est très floral.
Effectivement, il y a des agrumes.
C'est très agréable.
Très, très agréable.
Bravo. Bravo, le Nord.
-Le vin du Nord.
-1er vin du Nord.
-François-Xavier a raison,
il faut s'en réjouir,
c'est sympa
pour ces vignerons du Nord,
mais c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
pour la planète.
On fera du vin en Ecosse
et au Groenland,
donc c'est pas terrible.
-Tant qu'ils arrêtent pas
le whisky, les Ecossais, ça me va.
-Comment il est né... comment
est née l'histoire de ce livre
où on parle beaucoup de vin,
où on vous voit souvent
un verre à la main avec des amis,
avec des chefs,
des sommeliers, etc. ?
-C'est l'idée.
En fait, je viens d'avoir 50 ans
et je me suis dit,
il faut que je réalise ce rêve
de prendre ma route des vins
et d'aller à la rencontre de tous
ces amis que j'ai,
passionnés par le vin,
par ces régions. Gwilherm de Cerval,
qui est un sommelier qui cartonne
sur les réseaux sociaux
et qui est journaliste culinaire.
Vous avez,
je vais aller goûter
des Mitjavile
avec mon ami Stéphane de Groodt.
Là, on arrive dans le domaine
Mirmanda justement, dans le sud,
du côté du cirque de Vingrau
avec Dominique Laporte.
On va rencontrer
Anne-Sophie Pic dans le Rhône,
chez Laurent Combier,
Yves Gangloff,
des Côte-Rôtie,
des Crozes-Hermitage. On va aller
en Alsace chez Philippe Blanc,
dans le Jura
avec Stéphane Tissot,
chez Thierry Germain dans la Loire,
qui est un prêtre de la biodynamie.
Voilà, c'est à chaque fois...
-Dans toutes les régions de France.
-Exactement.
A la rencontre de passionnés
et de gens
qui parlent de transmission,
de leur passion,
de leur métier, de leurs doutes,
de leurs prises de risque.
-C'est une encyclopédie du vin.
Il y a beaucoup d'infos.
-Il y a des anecdotes,
des recettes.
-Oui, il y a des petites questions
à la con.
-Ca, on est
toujours contents.
J'allais dire,
l'épicurien, le jouisseur,
on a passé 40 minutes à table avec
vous, on a compris qui vous êtes,
c'est vrai. Vous aimez
les gueuletons, la bonne chère,
vous êtes pas un peu fatigué
de cette période où chaque excès
est
un peu sanctionné, limité.
C'est pas un problème pour vous ?
-Je sais si chaque excès est limité,
en tout cas,
il y a des convictions,
pour moi, qui sont compatibles,
c'est-à-dire que...
Je comprends tout à fait
les gens qui sont
végétariens,
je comprends tout à fait
les mouvements de conscientisation
de ce qu'on mange
et je les respecte énormément.
Voilà, quand un boucher
effectivement
que je connais me dit :
"Moi, tu sais,
c'est une bête par semaine.
"C'est tout. C'est de ça que je vis.
"Et je respecte mes animaux
"et je les nourris bien,
ils sont à l'air."
J'ai pas envie
de lui jeter la pierre.
J'ai envie de lui dire bravo.
Donc, moi, c'est vrai
que je mange moins de viande.
Mais elle est
meilleure.
Donc, je crois que c'est bien,
le zéro kilomètre, c'est parfait,
c'est mon voisin
qui vient me livrer
ma cagette
de légumes oubliés.
Certains, on comprend pourquoi.
-On n'a pas envie
de les faire revenir
au goût du jour.
-Continuons à les oublier.
Je crois que c'est sain et ça va
dans le bon sens. Les dogmes,
les excès, les sectaires,
c'est un peu gonflant, c'est sûr.
-Souvent, on a du mal
à voir la personne
qui mange moins de viande,
moins de poisson,
qui se concentre sur les légumes,
on a l'impression
que c'est moins gourmand,
qu'on prend moins de plaisir
autour de la table.
-Alors, moi,
je suis parti en week-end
avec des végétariens
et on s'est régalés.
C'était délicieux.
Il faut dire ce qui est, on était
très légers
pendant tout le week-end,
avec des légumes
cuits à la perfection,
des épices, c'était merveilleux.
-C'est pas forcément
triste d'être végétarien,
végétalien.
-Non, ça dépend
avec qui on pratique.
-Et on partage aussi.
-Exactement !
-Il y a aussi
votre spectacle,
qui s'appelle "Di(x)vin(s)".
-Voilà, on y revient.
-Il est très vin quand même.
-Pas divin, mais "Di(x)vin(s)".
-Ca peut être divin aussi.
C'est un prétexte, vraiment.
-On fait comme on veut.
-C'est comme la bande originale
de ma vie. Je vais me servir
de... d'une bouteille pour ramener
un souvenir, c'est une madeleine
de Proust. Ca permet
d'aller chercher
des souvenirs d'enfance,
de voyager dans le temps.
C'est une équation à plein
d'entrées, le vin.
-Une bouteille va
avec chaque souvenir ?
-J'ai voulu ce prétexte,
ça aurait pu être la bande originale
avec des musiques,
des films. Le vin,
ça me correspondait bien
et après cette longue période
de distanciation, il était
temps de se retrouver.
J'ai créé ce spectacle
après le confinement,
comme une envie de se retrouver
autour d'un verre. J'ai utilisé
ce prétexte des bouteilles
pour voyager, mais c'est
pas un spectacle sur le vin,
pas du tout une conférence
sur le vin.
-Plutôt sur l'amitié.
-Sur cette passion
que j'ai pour la scène
depuis 20 ans.
-Justement, on va la regarder,
la bande-annonce.
-Avec plaisir.
Applaudissements
...
Ma fille, elle a 16 ans.
Elle m'appelle plus papa,
mais le sang.
"T'inquiète, le sang."
Musique classique
...
-On te paie des cours de maths,
sans résultat. Elle répond :
"On te paie des cours de gym,
sans résultat."
C'est toi le plus fort.
Tu bois un coup ?
Je t'aime, mon amour. C'est
comme coucher avec Francis Cabrel.
Ici, c'est le rugby,
viens faire un bisou !
Marrade...
Il y a des ampoules claquées
au pays des Lumières.
...
-François-Xavier Demaison,
rappelez-nous les dates.
-Alors, ce sera du 28 décembre
au 13 janvier
pour les toutes dernières
parisiennes.
-Théâtre de l'Oeuvre.
Votre théâtre.
-J'ai la joie
de le diriger depuis 8 ans.
Et puis, ensuite, la tournée
qui est en ce moment, là.
Je voyage beaucoup, je me déplace
beaucoup et qui sera en tournée
jusqu'à fin mars.
Et après, c'est fini.
Donc de nouvelles aventures.
-Votre fille vous inspire beaucoup.
-Oui, vous la connaissez pas,
c'est...
J'aurais pu lui
consacrer un spectacle.
-Elle l'a vu, qu'en a-t-elle pensé ?
-Elle est très pudique vis-à-vis
de tout ce que je fais,
ça la fait beaucoup rire
et ça l'amuse
que j'aie pu m'inspirer
de... voilà, de notre relation et
surtout de ses saillies permanentes.
-Vous avez du mal à suivre ?
-Ah non, mais elle a
une repartie incroyable.
Elle a un culot.
Elle me fait hurler de rire,
vraiment.
-Quel acteur, on le voit. Il vient
d'avoir 50 ans. Vous vieillissez
comme un bon vin ?
-C'est à vous de le dire, mais
je trouve qu'on tient bien la route.
-Vous avez aussi
vécu à New York, on l'a dit
au début de l'émission, avant 2001.
Vous travailliez à l'époque
dans la finance.
-Alors, finance, oui,
j'étais
chez PricewatherhouseCoopers,
qui est une boîte de conseils,
j'étais pas sur les marchés.
-On s'est intéressés
aux restos américains,
florissants en France,
un comble au pays de la gastronomie.
On met Les pieds dans le plat.
-Il y a longtemps que le hamburger
ricain a colonisé nos tables,
mais d'autres totems
de la cuisine américaine
débarquent. Tour d'horizon
avec Dario Borgogno,
Marion Duvauchelle
et Yvana Navion.
-Qui dit nourriture américaine
dit burger,
ce plat classique des Etats-Unis se
retrouve partout. 80 % des 200 000
restaurants en France présentent
un burger dans leur menu. A Paris,
le 1er à l'avoir servi, c'est
Joe Allen, une référence
depuis 1972.
-Je suis venue il y a 30 ans,
c'est une vieille institution ici.
Voilà, donc j'amène ma fille, je lui
fais connaître les bonnes adresses.
-Pas question de parler
de malbouffe ici,
les burgers sont faits maison.
-La viande,
elle est hachée ici.
C'est de la bonne viande.
Il y a un pourcentage
de viande et de gras
pour que le burger soit "juicy".
Et les tomates sont fraîches,
les pickles sont frais,
tout est frais,
les frites sont faites maison,
c'est pas
de la malbouffe,
c'est juste un burger frites
avec tranche de tomate,
salade, pickles, cornichons
et cheddar
sur le burger.
-Le cheddar justement,
on le retrouve
dans un autre grand classique
de la cuisine américaine,
le mac and cheese,
surnom de macaronis
au fromage.
Dans ce restaurant du 20e,
on ne sert que ça,
une idée venue directement
de New York.
-En bas de mon bâtiment à Brooklyn,
un mec faisait
des mac and cheese traditionnels
et un jour, je lui ai dit,
si je rentre en France, je ferais
des mac and cheese
avec des fromages français.
Ceux qui ne connaissent pas
ont parfois des appréhensions
et ils découvrent
un plat avec des vraies saveurs,
des vrais ingrédients,
c'est assez agréable
de pouvoir surprendre
même avec un plat de pâtes.
-Je suis venue
pour faire plaisir à mon fils,
il est fan de gastronomie
américaine, moi, je suis fan
de gastronomie française. C'est
l'union des deux entre la qualité
des fromages, l'assemblage
et puis la créativité. Même moi,
j'apprécie, on mange ensemble.
-Etre ensemble
autour de plats américains
était aussi l'idée
de la famille Benitah.
Ils ont créé à Paris un deli,
typique de la Grosse Pomme,
avec un ingrédient star,
un morceau de viande
bien particulier.
-Le pastrami est une poitrine
de boeuf que l'on met en saumure,
donc avec de l'eau,
du sel et des épices.
On la laisse mariner. Ensuite,
on la roule dans les épices,
on la fume,
on la cuit pour la pasteuriser
et on la coupe en fines tranches
après l'avoir passée en étuve.
Il se mange
autant de pastrami à New York
qu'il peut se manger
de jambon en France.
Donc c'est vraiment
une culture très, très
new-yorkaise, le pastrami.
-Faits pour être emportés,
ces sandwichs sont très prisés.
-Mmh ! Extra !
Super croquant, super savoureux.
Trop bon.
-Des saveurs américaines
appréciées par d'anciens
New-Yorkais nostalgiques,
n'est-ce pas,
François-Xavier Demaison ?
-Eh oui.
Je les connais.
-Ca s'appelle un flagrant délit.
-Ils sont adorables.
-Une envie de pastrami ?
-D'abord, c'est délicieux.
-Oui, j'adore.
-Ils sont adorables. Et oui,
c'est...
-Vous avez connu à New York ?
-Le pastrami, oui. J'ai connu
chez Katz's Delicatessen.
-C'est des delicatessens,
c'était tenu
par des juifs ashkénazes.
-Exactement. Dans le quartier
de Lower East Side et j'habitais
pas très loin. J'adorais manger
mon sandwich pastrami
chez Katz's Delicatessen,
c'est là
que Meg Ryan a un orgasme
dans "Quand Harry rencontre Sally".
-Ah oui, OK !
-A cause du pastrami ?
-Non, je ne crois pas.
-Oui, peut-être aussi.
On les sert
avec ces gros concombres,
ces gros pickles aigres-doux,
les gros cornichons pardon.
-Qu'on appelle les malossols.
-Vous mangez
souvent de la cuisine américaine
à Paris ou vous évitez
parce que vous en avez...
-Non,
j'adore, mais un bon burger,
c'est merveilleux.
-On en trouve dans 80 %
des cartes aujourd'hui
des restaurants, hein.
-C'est très bon,
avec une bonne viande, bien cuit,
j'ai des souvenirs
quand j'allais dans des restaurants
d'Américaines qui s'extasiaient :
"Oh my God, just amazing !
"Oh my God, this is so good !
I love it.
"This is good."
-Qui prennent
des photos après.
-Elles font attention à leur ligne,
il y a un dilemme.
-C'est le "Dinner experience",
on va chez Jean-Georges.
Accent anglais
On va chez Daniel Boulud.
-Grand restaurateur
français, Boulud.
-Il y a des restaurants
qui sont mythiques à New York.
Mais la cuisine américaine,
c'est super convivial.
-C'est gras.
-Le Philly cheesesteak aussi,
tout ce qui est cheesecake,
moi, j'adore. Non, c'est
super sympa.
-Le mac and cheese,
vous saliviez.
-Il me faut l'adresse.
-Près du Père-Lachaise.
-C'est pas de la malbouffe,
c'est fait maison.
-Bien sûr !
-Le hamburger,
c'est pas de la malbouffe ?
-Mais pas du tout !
Je suis peut-être un peu monté dans
les aigus avec ce "pas du tout".
-Pas du tout.
-Non, c'est pas
de la malbouffe.
-Si c'est de la bonne viande,
du bon pain
et du bon bacon, c'est fabuleux.
Peut-être pas
à manger tous les jours.
Mais un steak
industriel,
du pain industriel, salé, sursalé,
c'est de la malbouffe.
-Avec ce qu'ils rajoutent
dans les chaînes.
-Les sauces aussi.
-Oui, je vais vous dire,
c'est peut-être honteux, mais
le lendemain d'une grosse soirée,
je suis content
d'aller chercher mon McDo.
Venir à "Politiques, à table !"
et faire
ce coming-out !
-Franchement !
-A New York aussi,
les slices de pizza.
-Ah oui !
-C'est inimitable.
-Exactement.
-La pâte est croûtée un peu.
-Oui, il y a quelque chose.
-On revient à la cuisine italienne.
-Oui, mais ça,
c'est la pizza new-yorkaise.
-Quand vous passez
dans ces steakhouses, vous avez
ce graillon végétal, je ne sais pas
ce que c'est, mais c'est délicieux.
-Vous êtes plutôt hamburger
ou jambon-beurre ?
Le burger a dépassé
le jambon-beurre.
-J'ai envie de vous dire les deux.
J'ai du mal à être très engagé
sur mes choix, j'adore
les deux,
j'adore un bon burger, c'est
merveilleux, vraiment.
-Un bon jambon...
-Bien sûr. Un bon beurre.
Un bon Comté.
-Avec la baguette.
-Rien de meilleur !
-On s'entend tous
sur cette espèce de cuisine
street-food américaine,
vous, quand vous étiez
aux Etats-Unis, vous avez vu une
gastronomie américaine ? Ca existe ?
-Alors, il y avait un restaurant
que j'adorais du côté de Brooklyn,
qui s'appelait Henry's End,
à Brooklyn Heights,
c'était un restaurant de cuisine
cajun, toute cette cuisine
de Louisiane, qui était
très particulière, des poulets,
de la friture,
mais avec une certaine
finesse. Je crois
que, quand on est dans un endroit,
il faut manger local,
il faut être super ouvert
et voilà, il y a rien de plus triste
que quelqu'un qui recherche
ce qu'il a laissé
15 jours chez lui pour aller
essayer... Non,
il faut s'adapter, être ouvert.
-Le poulet frit, c'est un truc
qui cartonne, qu'on retrouve aussi
en France avec des enseignes,
importées des Etats-Unis.
On prend quelques kilos.
-C'est votre émission
qui fait grossir,
rien qu'en parlant...
-A la fin, vous aurez
pris quelques kilos.
Vous serez pas déçu.
On a tous fini,
on va passer au dessert,
Le péché mignon.
-Ah !
Avec un fiadone,
c'est le gâteau de fête corse
par excellence,
qui a pour ancêtre le fiadoni,
un flan italien de Corte au départ,
il se déguste sur toute l'île
pour les fêtes de Pâques,
les baptêmes, les mariages.
On retrouve
des produits 100 % corses,
le fameux Brocciu,
des zestes de citron ou d'orange, de
l'eau de vie,
locale, l'acquavita,
on peut aussi trouver du cédrat,
un autre agrume.
C'est vraiment le souvenir
de votre enfance ?
-Oui.
A Saint-Florent, ma mère est corse,
elle s'appelle Ghisoni,
mon 2e prénom, c'est Toussaint,
François-Xavier, déjà marqué
très corse, Toussaint.
Mes parents voulaient...
-Marquer le coup.
-Il y a I Muvrini
et Jean-François Bernardini
qui fait un très beau texte
sur la Corse
et le vin dans le livre.
Et effectivement, le fiadone,
c'est toute mon enfance. Ce sont
des saveurs tellement particulières.
Je me souviens,
on allait chercher le fiadone
chez mon cousin,
José Salge, qui est
pâtissier à Saint-Florent,
il arrivait avec le fiadone,
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce goût ?
C'est très particulier,
c'est délicieux. C'est un flan,
mais avec des agrumes,
du citron, c'est très particulier.
-C'est un fromage,
le brocciu, qu'on peut sucrer
éventuellement. On le mange
salé ou sucré.
-Exactement.
C'est comme la feta en Grèce,
qu'on mange avec du miel. Mais ça,
c'est le cheesecake
corse.
-J'allais le dire.
-C'est des souvenirs
d'anniversaires,
de fêtes de famille ?
-Oui, c'est ça.
C'est le cheesecake corse.
-Délicieux !
Mmh. Il ressemble
à celui de votre enfance ?
-Mais oui, merci.
On a fait ce qu'on a pu.
-On l'a trouvé
dans un restaurant corse de Paris.
C'est compliqué à trouver,
un fiadone à Paris.
-Vous êtes très sucré
ou pas ? Souvent,
quand on est très salé, on n'est pas
forcément les deux.
Si, vous aimez tout ?
-Je suis moins sucré que salé,
mais quand la pâtisserie est
vraiment hors-norme,
c'est merveilleux. Mais oui,
j'aime bien terminer un repas
avec un vin liquoreux
ou un oxydatif
comme le Banyuls, le Mori,
voilà, un coteaux-du-Layon,
un Sauternes,
et j'aime bien terminer
avec ce sucre-là.
Mais là, le fiadone,
vous allez me faire pleurer.
-Les 2 vont ensemble.
-Je vais chanter le "Salve Regina".
Il chante.
Voilà.
-Justement, on finit
toujours en musique,
sauf que c'est pas ça,
vous nous avez demandé autre chose.
On écoute.
"365 jours", Oxmo Puccino
...
-Le bruit de la pluie sur le bitume
En panne d'essuie-glace
Mon pare-brise pleure
Mon humeur durcit la glace
Ceux qui disent Le temps
C'est de l'argent sont dans l'erreur
Si on met les zéros de côté
Pas les heures
Je commande un café
avant le texte pondu
-Vous nous avez demandé
cette chanson.
-J'adore Oxmo
Puccino. Et j'adore cette chanson.
-"365" ?
-Ah ouais, elle me rend dingue.
-Vous l'écoutez
souvent ?
-Chaque fois que je cours.
Chaque fois que je cours, je mets
cette musique et...
-Ca vous booste ?
-Oui, ça me vide la tête,
ça me booste. J'adore.
C'est un poète,
une plume incroyable.
Oxmo. Voilà, j'adore.
-Vous écoutez tous ses albums ?
En concert ?
-Oui, je suis très fan.
-Donc on finit
avec cette chanson. Merci.
Merci de l'avoir fait découvrir.
-Il est génial...
-Très sympa.
-Ecoutez, j'ai passé
un moment merveilleux.
-Le fiadone, c'est chez Minnà,
rue d'Hauteville à Paris.
-Merci !
-Bravo !
J'ai passé un moment privilégié
et je vous remercie
du fond du coeur. J'adore
l'émission,
vous avez su nous montrer
les hommes politiques
d'une façon extrêmement
intéressante, humaine
et constructive.
-Merci à vous d'avoir
accepté de prendre
la place d'un politique.
-C'est ça. Avec humilité.
-Merci.
-Très bon spectacle et ce livre,
"Tournée générale :
ma route des vins",
que vous pouvez déguster aussi.
Merci à tous de nous avoir suivis.
Merci, Jean-Pierre.
Rendez-vous la semaine prochaine
pour "Politiques, à table !"
sur LCP.
...
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA